hi everyone welcome to another town
technique class at home I hope all of
you have been very well today's going to
be quite simple we are going to continue
with our method of combining simple
movements into complex feeders
interesting feeders so today we will
take steps forward and backward like
this people's clockwise counterclockwise
and crosses front and back and we will
combine them always in the same order
first we will always do our step then we
will do a pivot and then we will finish
with a cross and by changing which leg
we use left or right or which directions
we use for each one of these elements we
are going to find all kinds of
possibilities with these three movements
okay some of the possibilities will feel
familiar already because you already use
them for Heroes for aerospace and some
of them will be new and familiar but
that's the advantage of being systematic
that you find everything that there is
and the things that you didn't know yet
can give you new ideas for the doctor
yeah so we will start with a warm-up
first and the reason why I always
include the warm-up in each video even
if it's similar is because I want to
give you an experience that is as close
as possible to a life class with me so
when I teach in the tower school
obviously I always start with a workout
so I want
you can follow along as if you were
really doing a class with me okay
then afterwards I am going to show you
each combination in turn and I will need
a few technical tips that are specific
for each one and then we will do them
together okay so let's stop okay one
more place is going to be the usual
again so we start with feet together
remember to place your hip straight and
relax the shoulders if you want take a
few seconds to just breathe and let the
weight of your body go down to your feet
you have feel the pressure of your
weight on the feet on the ground and we
start with circles with the shoulders
going backwards yeah remember don't use
the elbows keep your arms relaxed and
straight yeah so we do eight one two
three four five
six seven eight he's like massage for
the upper back
yeah it should feel very relaxing okay
now we continue with eight circles with
the arms so remember you should keep
your elbow straight all the time you
start low then you go forward you will
up and here you open the arms to the
sides and you take the opportunity to
open the chest here to stretch the chest
muscles and then go down okay let's the
weight one two three four five six seven
okay now we will stretch the size of our
torso so we raise one part under the
head the hand is above our head and then
with the handle is on our leg we slide
down the leg until we can touch more or
less the selves are me yeah and of
course then we hold this edge for a few
seconds and then we use this hand
the handle is up to pull ourselves again
until we're straight and then I will
repeat with the other arm
okay so let's do four to each side so
start with one side now the other side
slide down the leg touch the knee to go
down the leg destiny hold it one two
three pull yourself up to the other side
I'm straight above your head slide down
your neck touch the knee hold it one two
three up three go down to your knee
enjoy the stretch and pull yourself up
and then other side down that's the knee
hold it up and the last time raise our
lower hundred me enjoy stretch pull
yourself up repeat to the other side
raised arm
[Music]
stage 1 2 3 ok now we will loosen and
stress parameter so we open the legs we
bend the knees slightly we make a circle
with our arms in front of us and then we
rotate the torso left and right be
careful
don't move the hip the belt is always
looking forward don't release yeah and
we go twice 8 times
ok so 1 2 3 4 5 6 ok
now straightening we stretch the lower
back so we will put the hands behind our
head don't forget to keep your hip place
all the time avoid this position yeah
keep your hips straight and then within
the back until we are parallel with the
floor and then we continue going down
relax let the weight of your head pull
your back down and then we bounce
signals 1 2 3 and then we stretch the
back again under the floor and then we
okay we will do this eight times okay
let's leave together so we're ready go
down one I am the third bounce to to run
into the box to slowly go down bounce
one two three four down five the third
bounce
one two three four one five one six down
bounce one two three seven go down
bounce one two three go
and the last one eight go down bounce
one two three go
fish okay now the next one we will keep
our legs open underneath straight grab
your hips and then it here is to go back
with your hip and then two circles with
the hip ladies
so from back you go to the side at this
point you should feel a stretch on the
inside of your leg then you are forward
then you go to the other side you should
feel a stretch on the other leg and then
back many people have a problem with his
exercise and they start doing this they
move the head they do the circle with
the head instead of the hip yeah make
sure that your head is more or less
static in one position and that you are
moving the hip you see my head is not
moving too much is the hip okay so let's
do eight on each direction so one two
three four five
six seven eight now change direction one
two three four five six seven eight okay
and the last one with clothes are legs
feet together
first we Bend our knees and we bounce
three down to the last pom pom pom one
two three and then we stretch the knees
we go slightly forward with our way
until the weight is on the toes and then
we push the floor down and we hold this
position for three seconds on the toes
okay
again remember make sure that your legs
are together you don't have space
between them and when you are up make
sure that the big toe is the top placing
the most on the floor don't allow your
feet to open eyes and keep them closed
okay so let's the weight
so grab your hips if you want and then
go down bounce one two three
strengthening and one two one two three
four one two three five one two three
one two three don't forget the hip
six one two three go up one two seven
one two three last one one two three one
one one two three okay
okay so we're finished with the warmup
let's go for their exercises okay so for
the first exercise we're going to do the
following
I'm going to show you from behind yeah
so we will start in zero position we
will do a step forward with the right
leg the right leg is going to be our
deleting them so we will forward the
step doesn't need to be very big just a
small step is okay and then we will do a
90 degrees p-word with the right foot
like this then we will finish with a
cross front and then we will go back and
change weight and then we'll repeat so
the structure is one with the same step
forward with right foot 90 degrees
people clockwise crossbones and bastard
right yeah step front people cross
forward step back
yeah so every time that it would be the
exercise you are turning 90 degrees now
a few technical things so that the
exercise is done correctly first you
have to start in zero position so I
recommend flex your knees place your
heel now when you do the step with the
right foot your torso should at the same
time turn slightly towards the direction
of the people as a preparation no
was only with the doors yeah now during
the whole exercise in general try to
move your feet always close to the floor
in contact with the floor don't lift
your feet don't do this
yeah now the next tip is that when you
do that people don't rush to do the
cross front you have many people do the
step and then they want to cross you
already know it's much better if you do
the people keeping the back leg behind
as long as you can
look you do the people and you keep the
leg behind and when the pivot is
finished then you worry about the cross
yeah
if I show you from behind again so you
do the step with the torso going towards
the right and then you do the people
keeping the leg behind and we finish the
people you close and the last tip is
that now your weight is on the foot that
did the cross and now you want to go
back so it's still going back directly
like this before touch the inside of
your standing foot yeah
don't go directly back with the right
foot but touch the inside yeah it's like
you want to do a zero position before
you go back but differently to do a
perfect zero position is enough that you
touch briefly the inside of your son
food when you change weight and then you
start again yeah Florence P World Cross
from
okay this is the first exercise so we
will do it together
first one side and then to the other
side going forward with left yeah and we
will do it with a metronome because I in
the same way
[Music]
[Applause]
1cor hi
God sweet
[Music]
okay right let's go to the next exercise
okay for the second exercise we're going
to change the clothes instead of
crossing from where it grows back
so the exercise that looks like this we
start from zero position we'll start
with right with pillow
clockwise 90 degrees and then we cross
back and then we can cross and we go
back and then we change weight yeah so
front with right clockwise people 90
degrees close behind and cross the right
foot go back change weight to the left
and we'll be yeah now for the technique
that is everything we said for the first
exercise applies so use torture when you
are going to people on the first step
keep your feet on the floor all the time
don't lift your feet yeah and here there
is a special bit for this one because
now the process is going to is going to
be bad instead of front yeah so the same
as before
don't rush into the close-in still
moving the back foot straight into the
process in people like things many
people to Christ to the people keeping
the leg behind and then crossing yeah
I'm sure it from behind with respect
instead of pivoting and person
immediately know the step people keeping
the leg back and ankles and why do it
like this well because it's more
if you think about it if you go straight
into the cross your back foot is going
to draw a straight line on the floor
it's going to go straight envelopes but
if you keep the food behind as you pivot
and then you cross your foot is going to
draw an arc part of a circle instead of
straight and that's more beautiful is
surrounder yeah okay so try that and
let's do it together again
sixteen times to each side 26.7 got
eight back eight more
[Music]
three four five six seven eight okay
good now it's in the same to the other
side starting going forward with the
left neck okay so we are ready zero
position blends your hip bend your knees
God God God God see
[Music]
seven okay okay hey if you notice I'm
not doing very big steps the exact time
I don't have a lot of space for this
otherwise you will lose my feet when I
come close to the camera so this is
enough
yeah if you want you to have more space
and you want to do big steps then why
not yeah but if you do it with small
steps is also good
okay let's go to the next exercise okay
for the next exercise we are going to
change the direction of the people and
we're going to keep crossing front so
it's going to look like this you start
from zero position you step forward with
the right leg and now instead of
building towards the living leg you'll
be what away from the leading edge so
you people like this yeah and then you
cross front and then you go back and
change weight so the structure is now
ladies step front with right 90 degrees
pila counterclockwise Crossland and step
back change weight step front with right
90 degrees people counter clockwise
cross from his left and mobile right
okay
now the technique tips are very
consistent from exercise to exercise you
store should keep it on the floor keep
freely behind as long as you can now
this is interesting because I'm going to
show you from this side because it's
better after you do the step yeah now
I'm going to be what to this side yeah
to your left
so most people what they do is
and they and they directly into the
cross ladies yeah so the back foot does
a straight line towards the clothes this
is not wrong but we can do something a
bit better yeah which is using the same
logic from the previous exercise keep
the back leg behind as long as you can
during the build ladies and then do the
cross from behind
so the movement will look like this yeah
so instead of doing a straight line in
your food like is boom you will do a
kind of art that goes back and forth
yeah it will be like one but it will be
round like an S yeah one more time the
foot is behind I people I keep the leg
behind that's the first part of the S
yeah and then here the second part of
this yeah and this is a more interesting
movement yeah
and then remember the last it once you
have clothes then remember to touch
briefly the inside of your standing foot
with the right foot before you go back
ok good so let's do it together
16 times 2 inside so zero position
remember these small steps for the
exercise
bah-bah-bah a 1:1 God God God God
five six seven eight
God okay now he's going to the other
side by going forward with left
I'm giving all right
[Music]
three four five six seven eight
okay good let's go to the next exercise
okay so for the next exercise where we
have to change our clothes instead of
front it will be back yeah so the
exercises as possible to start into your
position you're front with the right
foot and then you do your pivot counter
clockwise 90 degrees and then you cross
back then you uncross the right foot you
go back and let me change weight so the
structure is like this step front with
white people might release
counterclockwise close back and close
man step back change weight step from do
it right p1 90 degrees counter clockwise
cross but we've left
uncross the right buh-bah change weight
so here let's see what happens with the
free leg when you people yeah so this
one is easier now
because after the step yeah let's see
what happens with this there so when you
people to counterclockwise the people
will naturally bring this leg back like
he did before but now you just have to
cross back so it's very easy the only
thing I can tell you about this is to
follow the logic from the previous steps
try to keep the leg behind as long as
you can when people don't rush into the
back cross allow the arc of the three
food to finish before you cross
yeah so then instead of a straight line
like this you have more like this yeah
from behind you're here instead of going
with this leg not straight into the
cross what you do is that the people
keeping the leg behind and then you
cross okay that's the main tip for this
one so 16 times again okay bye
[Music]
got seven back eight god
okay now this before
quick the ethnic we people to the right
God for ba Chi God
cease not seven got eight got eight more
one dude
3.45 sweets God God a okay great let's
go to the next exercise
okay so we have done all the
possibilities that we could put in
upheaval on the front step now we have
to put the pivot on the back step so for
this first exercise of the second half
we are going to do this now I'm going to
start the exercise a little bit more
forward than before
yeah then the right leg is going to be
on believing it so I go front with the
right leg and then I change weight with
left and then I go back with right and
here we are going to put the people we
are going to be what clockwise like we
did before
so we pivot this way and then we use
across from which is the most natural
thing to when we come from this side and
then uncross the right foot and go
forward
yeah and this is the next repetition so
this is the structure step forward with
the right leg change where it moves left
step up with right 90 dB PMON clockwise
cross front with left and cross with
right step front
change weight step back people clockwise
cross front and then yeah now the
technique let's see what happens with
when we peeled yeah I'm going to show
you profile so you see it better so you
are going from a yoga mat and now you
have to be with so let's use the same
logic that we did for the previous
exercises when we people now to decide
instead of trying to go with your free
food directly into the clothes doing a
straight line and rushing it
No relax the neck relax the neck and
people keeping the leg where it is so
naturally this leg will go front and
then you cross the pivot this is better
because the effect like before is that
instead of drawing a straight line with
your free food like this when you do is
that you draw an arc with your free food
service it's round and it's more
beautiful okay okay so that's doesn't it
so let's lay together 16 bags to each
side okay so get ready zero position
place your cheap
[Music]
by God hello 6.7 God verse 8 God go
sigma-1 got crooks ooh God
gross but those poor God knows God got
those seats back those seven got close
eight god yes okay now let's do it
together side going forward with left
okay one got close to God oops
three dot plus four
[Music]
oops
fine got oops seats doc dos city got
books eight o'clock go same on one bar
hooks to God goes the got goes for got
oops I got those seats doc dos
God plus weight God
oops okay very good
let's go to the next exercise
okay for the next exercise we will
change our clothes so instead of
crossing forward we will cross back
so the exercise looks like you start
from zero then you go forward with the
leading leg which is the right one then
you change weight and you go back you
people clockwise 90 degrees and this
time you cross back and then you go from
and we beat yeah that's the structure
step front with right change weight with
left step back with right people come on
please close back with length and then
go forward with right and repeat change
weight go back with right people
clockwise close back with left and go
forward with right yeah that's the
structure so maybe you saw it already
what happens with the free leg when you
pee what we have another s again yeah
look I'll show you from the side yeah so
you start from zero
you have front you change with an
arugula now you have to be worth 90
degrees clockwise like this so instead
of going with the free food in a
straight line towards the cross-language
which most people do and it's not wrong
but we can try something else now
instead of that you relax your free leg
and when he was
you let the leg go forward which is
counterintuitive but after they goes
forward then you can retract the foot
and cross behind so instead of a
straight line woman you're free food
will do a kind of s yeah this is the
first part of the X and then as you
finish the people you do the second part
of this so it's like legs and then
remember the last tip now you want to go
forward so before that you have to touch
lightly quickly the inside of your
standing foot with your right foot with
a fearful yes so yeah typically when you
cross back and then you have to go
forward it's a bigger control you lose
your balance
this step is forwards over you're
falling so if you touch the inside in
the zero position this will force you to
find your balance on the back foot and
then the step fold will be very
controlled and on time okay good so
let's do that success together
sixteen times to each side yeah we'll
start with the right leg first four five
six eight got eight more one goes
plus three Oh God goes for but goes five
dot plus C's Oh God
plus seven Oh God
Bruce hey buck goes okay now it's me to
the other side going forward with left
one dot plus two
God goes for goes five Oh God
pulse six God goes seven God goes hey
God
go save more one Oh God
close good God
gross 3 God
close close fight Oh God
oops sees God kills seven Bob goes wait
god gross okay look this one Miami is a
little bit weak with his ass going front
and then back so many you want to use
this move
but it's good that you complete Anatomy
exercise because it will give you much
more awareness of what you can do with
your feet yeah
even if you don't use it it's always
better to be able to do it than not to
know it okay good so let's go to the
next exercise
okay for the next exercise we're going
to change the direction of the people we
have been building clockwise now we're
going to be with counterclockwise so the
exercise is going to Louganis we start
in zero position
you know from with the right foot then
you change weight then you go back with
the right foot and now we pivot 90
degrees counterclockwise so this way and
then we will use a cross front because
it's the easiest possibility in this
position and then you cross the right
foot and you start again so the
structure is always like this step front
with right change weight with left step
back with right people 90 degrees
counter clockwise cross front with left
and cross right and for right yeah
change wait go back
PBOT 90 degrees counterclockwise cross
from funding forward yeah that's the
structure so as you can see we again use
the same technique for the free leg I'm
going to show you on this side yeah so
you will front you change weight and
then you go back now you people
counterclockwise soon this way so with
the free food we do the following in
still doing a straight line brushing the
clothes like this you know what we do is
that we relax this leg yeah and then
when we people we let we allow this left
stay where it is in front language and
then we close so instead of a straight
line
yeah the lady's going to do an arc onion
till it closes its like part of the
symbol and this is always more beautiful
okay
and then we uncross when you cross this
I think it's obvious said it before but
I repeat it
don't lift your foot yeah especially if
you do this exercise fast try to keep
your big toe always in contact with the
floor and do a small circle around your
feet food Yogi's we have worked a lot in
previous classes okay so let's do it
together
sixteen times we start with the right
God - for God goes by God
those seats God goes seven eight one two
three four
first guy I got close Z's God goes 7 na
ba + God gross
ok now to the other side starting with
the left leg forward 1 + + 304
god girls God pump got closed sees God
goes 7 God
gross hey God go Sigma 1 Oh God
goes to God goes free God goes for back
good 5 I got goose sees God goes 7 oh
god gross 8
got goats okay great so let's go for the
next exercise
okay so for the last it is
to change her clothes instead of
crossing front we're going to cross back
okay so that's a sense now looks like
this
we start from zero position and you go
from with the right foot when you change
weight with the left you go back with
right and many people 90 degrees
counterclockwise in this direction and
then it is across back okay and then you
repeat the same structure you will float
with right change weight with left but
with right people 90 degrees counter
clockwise close back with left and front
with right and so on okay now let's see
about the technique of the free leg and
here this combination is special because
you have two possibilities of what you
can do with your freedom look I'll show
you from the profile because it's easier
to see you go front with right change
way and then go back and now you have to
be with 90 degrees in this direction so
if you want you could allow the momentum
of the pivot to continue on the free leg
and let it open to the side yeah this is
what the leg would naturally do if you
use the momentum of the people and then
what happens is that you can do
that naturally finishes in your bag
across so this will be one way to do it
people
Lucky's under crossbar another option
you have is to do it more control so
when you people you don't allow the leg
to open but once the leg is in front
then you withdraw the food and you move
your free leg very close to the standing
leg language so there is no not from
here we do the pivot you will ask the
leg you keep it in front and then you
close with really tight around your
standing leg yeah I am going to use the
second variation yeah the second way of
doing it because it means a bit more
control it's not so intuitive yeah and
it makes more control with a free leg
okay it's a bit more difficult and I
believe but as always in this case is up
to you you can do either of them okay um
the last thing don't forget after
applause now we're going to work forward
so don't forget to touch with your free
food the inside of your standing foot
before you go forward in this case is
especially important because when you
cross bar usually you have some momentum
to a forward and very often the step
forward we do it directly it's very
uncontrolled that is to only and it
feels a
yeah after the close of bathtub so if
you do this movement if you touch the
other side of your standing foot it
forces you to find the balance on your
standing
yeah okay okay seven eight okay good now
16 batters waiting for wait
okay very good so that was it that was
the last exercise I think we covered all
the possibilities if you find another
one please let me know because I haven't
okay and of course as always I recommend
these exercises and they feel good and
then challenge yourself bilious
challenge is of course to increase the
tempo and drive faster and this is the
advantage of working with a metonym that
you can increase your tempo in small
increments I recommend you if you want
work on speed don't try to do it very
fast too early because your technique
will fall apart if you work too fast the
speed that you are not using it your
your feet will be bad positions are we
so do it in small increments yeah so
that each increment feels easy because
you are already used to the previous
speed and then without noticing
increment by increment you will be doing
it faster in a shorter time ok another
thing you can do is to try these
exercises with peoples of hundred eighty
degrees instead of only 90 yeah let me
know in the comments if you would like
me to record a video with these bigger
peoples yeah or if you find it on your
own as homework ok so let me know thank
you very much I hope you like this class
and see you in the next one bye